What a do comrade?
I read your comments
And this week on Thug Notes we goin' ham
with Animal Farm by George Orwell
It's all gravy up at the Manor Farm 'til
one night a prize boar by the name of Ol' Major
has a trippy ass dream
So this porker hollars at his animal homies
to preach some of that raw gospel
Major say that men are the only creature on the farm
that consume ev'rything, but don't produce nothing
which means the only thing standing between the animals and righteous livin'
is stepping to and stomping their two legged oppressors
Rebellion dawg
One night the animals rise up and kick Farmer Jones n his boys straight to the curb
Finally the boss of they own turf the animals redub this bad boy Animal Farm
and lay down a new rap called Animalism
Up in this crib the main verse is that "All animals are equal."
After the dust settle two pigs named Napoleon and Snowball start calling the shots
Thing is they always gettin up in each other's grill
When some humans try to throw down and take back the farm those animals don't play
They straight beast these fools and send 'em packin
Then Napoleon and Snowball start beefing about the idea of building a windmill
When the other animals start sidin' with Snowball Napoleon gets all crunk and chases 'em off the farm
Another pig named Squealer start tellin' ev'rybody that Snowball was nothing but a snitch and a traitor
Now while all the other animals bustin they ass building a windmill
the pigs realize that some of the swag they need they just can't get on they own
so they hit up their two legged enemies and start trading with them on the reg
Over time the seven commandments of Animalism get
twisted little by little
until one day only one remains all
animals are equal
but some animals are more equal than others
Eventually the pigs get so crooked that they start struttin' exactly  like humans
walkin' two legged with whips of oppression in hand
And in the end there ain't nobody who can tell the difference between pigs and humans
Looks like we're back where
we started
Listen up comrade this book ain't just a story about animals
On the real Orwell dropping some mad allegory about the rise and fall of the Soviet Union
See the pigs representin the top dogs of the
the Communist Party
Napoleon stands for Stalin the Soviet dictator
Whereas Snowball really be Trotsky
the communist leader who's beef with Stalin got his ass slung out of Russia
Squealer's smooth talking tendencies representin' Pravda
the newspaper that spit lies to the people in order to further Stalin's cause
Old Major's a mix of Karl Marx, the O.G. commie theorist
and Vladimir Lenin the brain behind the revoultion
When Old Major preachin' to the animals his rhyme got the same flavor as the end of the Communist Manifesto
The communists openly declare that their ends can be attained only by the forcible overthrow of all existing social conditions"
Working men of all countries unite!
Also the animal's revolt in chapter 2 echoing the Bolshevik Revolution of October 1917
against the Tsar who be Mr. Jones in the story
and the humans attempt to retake the
farm in Chapter four
reppin the civil war between the Russian loyalists and Bolsheviks in 1918
Now of all things why did Orwell use animals to chop game 'bout Soviet Union?
Well check this quote from Karl Marx's economic and philosophical manuscript of 1844
The worker in this human functions no
longer feels himself to be anything but animal
What is animal becomes human and what is human becomes animal.
But Animal Farm ain't just going off about one point in history
This book offering some legit truths about
all humanity
cuz no matter who you're with power can corrupt your mind
And even the realest homies like Boxer are liable to start worshipping a crooked ass leader
But you know what's mad ironic B?
If you keepin' it literal up in here the revolution that went down at Manor Farm was actually legit
By definition a revolution ends where it began
Cuz the porky players that stared out getting f**ked by their human oppressors
are now the ones doing the f**king
Yo show your colors and get yourself a Thug Notes t-shirt son
See your ass next week playa